let's go instead to Keaton from San Jose
Keaton welcome to the program
what's on your mind today
and you do have to unmute yourself
Keaton
hey David can you hear me yes I can
great
um yeah so you had talked about this
during the the midterms and uh 2020 and
I'm
curious as to what you mean
when you say uh Democrats need to be on
the offense yeah
you're that's the you're just curious
what I mean by that
uh yeah I guess strategically
communicatively what that looks like
yeah so being on defense would be
Republican being on defense is the
status quo basically it's Republicans
make some claim these people on the left
want to make our country socialist or
they want to ruin this or they want to
indoctrinate your kids or whatever and
then Democrats come out and like they
get organized very slowly on their
talking points and then they come up
with something but it's just a defense
and then you sound defensive and
Republicans have already gotten out
ahead on the issue so you're kind of
just playing reactive Politics the truth
is Democrats given the disaster and joke
that is the Republican party where they
don't even pretend to be about policy
anymore the Democrats could put together
a much more proactive strategy to create
and take control of the news cycle
pointing out all the ways in which
Republicans if they got their way would
actively worsen the country for large
swaths of people so there's no it's not
a there's no hidden message it's just
Democrats need to be more proactive
rather than reactive I see
and and one last question sure
um I'm wondering if you
and and the mods or whoever it is are
planning on having another
chess tournament because I I actually
found you through
um
chess.com
Champions I think POG Champs yes well
that was a tournament that I organized
I'm open to doing another chess
tournament we're just so busy and we
have so many different things including
the children's book coming out soon and
other stuff I would gladly do another
chess tournament but it's on a list of
many things that we would like to do if
that's fair
of course all right well uh thanks a lot
David all right Keaton from San Jose
great to hear from you imagine for a
second that you try logging into your
email account only to find that your
password was changed an hour ago and
then you get notifications of activity
from your bank and then your credit
cards that is what identity theft is
like and it's a horrible feeling and we
dealt with it at the show not that long
ago but now I have an app called Aura
which gives me much more peace of mind
our sponsor Aura is the all-in-one
solution for keeping your online account
safe because Aura will scan the dark web
for your personal info passwords social
security number and you get fast alerts
when they find something you also get
fast alerts about credit inquiries Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware or even requests the removal of
your info from data broker sites and
Aura helps you manage what your kids can
do on their devices you can restrict
certain apps set screen time limits set
Focus times when you need them off of
devices go to aura.com Pacman to try it
free for seven days your login
credentials might already be floating
around out there and Aura will tell you
instantly for free the link is down
below